I have some fascinating video to dig
into today Donald Trump has been having
trouble on the issue of race lately
Donald Trump's reaction to huge national
protests against police brutality after
George Floyd was killed by police was to
say send in more force and have the
military dominate the protesters that
was the word he used last week or the
week before on a call with governors so
it's obviously not going well for Trump
on race Donald Trump is polling 8% with
black voters 8 8 % according to a new
CNN poll so someone got the bright idea
let's send Trump to be interviewed on
Fox News but not by one of their
ubiquitous white blond anchors have
black woman Harris Falkner interview
Donald Trump this is going to be great
it's going to help him with with black
voters
it was absolutely and utterly insane and
I want to look at some clips with you
today
here's Trump pulling out the
cringe-worthy claim about him doing more
for black people than any other
president and he weirdly says let's not
include Lincoln in that although he adds
it is questionable how much Abraham
Lincoln really did for black people to
which even Fox News anchor harris
faulkner has to say well we are free mr.
president like Lincoln freed the slaves
you've done more for us to check out
this first clip and strap in folks
because it's gonna be wild
it's just in general I mean the economy
is the great unifier right now I think
I've done more for the black community
than any other president and let's take
a pass on Abraham Lincoln because he did
good although it's always questionable
you know in other words the end result
we are free mr. president but we don't
wanna stay because you say you
absolutely bizarre this is the president
talking like this and he doesn't even
have the historical understanding to be
able to recognize how cringy this is
like its total cringe but he doesn't get
it because he lacks
historical knowledge Trump who has
defended Confederate monuments says he's
done more for black people than any
other president so then we get into the
meat of it as it were related to the
protests
Donald Trump says and this really
requires some deep thinking to know what
on earth is this guy talking about
Trump says that police chokehold as a
concept are innocent and perfect
innocent and perfect and then he totally
dissembles into nonsense yeah and I
think the concept of choke all sounds so
innocent so perfect and then you realize
if it's a one-on-one now if it's
two-on-one that's a little bit of a
different story depending depending on
the toughness and strength you know
we're talking about toughness and
strength we are talking there's a
physical thing here also but if a police
officer is in a bad scuffle and he's got
somebody for the life --all what is he
talking about
I'm not I'm not asking rhetorically what
is he talking about now understand that
there are lots of Republicans who will
say only 8% of black voters support
Trump because they've been somehow
tricked by Democrats or they've fallen
for something which implicitly suggests
black voters are dumb that they they've
been tricked by Democrats watch this
interview and you understand why Trump
is polling 8% with black voters here's
more about chokeholds Trump saying
sometimes bad people something-something
chokeholds are good that's I mean I have
a hard time making more sense out of it
than that say no I don't want to see
mistakes yeah I don't like Joe calls now
I will say this as somebody that you
know you grow up and you wrestle and you
fight and you this or you see what
happens
sometimes if you're alone and you
fighting somebody's tough and you get
somebody in a chokehold what are you
gonna do say oh and it's a real bad
person and you know that and they do
exist I mean we have some real bad
people you saw that during the last
couple of weeks you saw some very good
people protesting just saw some bad
people also and you get somebody in a
chokehold and what are you gonna do now
let go and say oh let's start all over
again I'm not allowed to have me in a
chokehold it's a tough situation now if
you have two people or another case and
the case that we're talking about two or
four people and two of them I guess just
pretty much started so it's a very very
very true
situation that's a joke all bang is good
because to talk about because of the
cuff it would sound like absolutely but
if you're thinking about it then you
realize maybe there is a bad fight and
the officer gets somebody in a position
I think you have to probably see you
want to be in that conversation it's
just not of this world
there's there's nothing there there's no
substance there to even really analyze
another absolutely Looney Tunes moment
from this interview they get into the
phrase Trump used when the looting
starts the shooting starts Trump used
this phrase during the protests recently
the origins are a guy named Walter
Headley the police chief of Miami
Florida who said it in the 60s when
there was a violent outbreak of crime
and it has a horribly racist history it
was positioned against the battle for
civil rights in the country at the time
and Trump was asked about the origins
and he kind of plays dumb he's like well
other people also said it like Philly
Police Commissioner Frank Rizzo used the
term now Rizzo did not actually use the
term but he did encourage brutal police
tactics and Trump just kind of says like
whoa Rizzo also said it which is not
technically true and then it gets just
really awkward if you if you have an
aversion to awkwardness I would maybe
skip the next two minutes me and and I'm
Paris on TV but I'm a black woman I'm a
mom and you know when and you've talked
about it but we haven't seen you come
out and be that consoler in this
instance and the tweets when the looting
starts the shooting starts why those
words so that's an expression I've heard
over the years Anna Dina warehouses - I
think Philadelphia the mayor of
Philadelphia
it comes from 1967 I was about 18 months
old at the time everybody's shooting
wiki because they probably got it wrong
but it was from the chief of police in
Miami he was cracking down and he meant
what he said and he said I don't even
care if it makes it look like brutality
I'm gonna
down when the looting starts the
shooting stars that frightened a lot of
people when you you told that it also
comes from a very tough mayor who I
might have been police commissioner at
the time but I think mayor of
Philadelphia named Frank Rizzo and he
had an expression like that but I've
heard it many times so I think it's been
used many times it means two things
very different things one is if there's
looting there's probably going to be
shooting and that's not as a threat
that's really just a fact because that's
what happens and the other is if there's
looting there's going to be shooting
this is very they're very different
meanings I'm interesting you know
there's very different meanings but I
think do you think most people see it
that way I think they see both was no I
mean I've had it viewed both ways I
think it's meant both ways can anybody
understand what he's talking about like
literally what is he saying I'm feeling
like my grammatical knowledge of English
is not up to par to properly parse what
Donald Trump is trying to say here so
let's now go backwards a little bit I'm
gonna go back to the start of the
interview with harris faulkner and trump
characterizes the protests really as
riots and unnecessary of course they
were mostly peaceful protests and they
were totally warranted given the
inaction on police brutality for so long
just completely dismissive Trump is of
the entire movement not exactly an
opportunity for a big coup with black
voters what's happened in the last
couple of weeks I feel like we are at
one of those historical moments where
future generations will look back and
they'll decide who we were are you the
president to unite all of us given
everything that's happening right now
well I certainly think so and I
certainly hope so and the relationships
we have are incredible the spirit of
this country and especially considering
what happened I mean we had out of
nowhere a plague come in from China he
just came in and it came to all over the
world it went all over the world you
looked at 186 countries and they were
devastated and we were certainly hit
very hard some were hit harder than us
relatively but we were hit very very
hard
and now we're making our comeback and
then on top of it we had the the riots
which were unnecessary to the extent
they were if the governors and mayor's
would have taken a stronger action I
think the riots would have been you
could call protesters you could call
them riot so different nights different
things says riots again says riots again
says you could call them protests but
they're really riots and then following
up this dismissive dismissiveness with
even more remember they sat him in front
of black fox news anchor harris faulkner
i guess as part of the optics here and
he just says horrible things here trump
says lots of the protest protesters
didn't even know why they were
protesting which is just completely
dismissive of the movement when he
called out mom on that tape it's a heart
punch so I'm curious from you what do
you think the protesters not not the
looters and the riders we're intelligent
enough to know the difference in our
country right what do you think they
want what do you think they need right
now from you so I think you'd protesters
for different reasons and then you had
protesting also because you know they
just didn't know I've watched i watch
you very closely why are you here and
they really weren't able to say but they
were there for a reason perhaps but a
lot of them really were there because
they're following the crowd a lot of
them they were there because what we
witnessed was a terrible thing what we
saw was a terrible thing and we've seen
it over the years we haven't you know
this was one horrible example but you've
seen other terrible examples you know
that better than anybody would would
know it yes black woman harris faulkner
would know better than anyone but again
protesters didn't know why they were
there according to Donald Trump so
listen you can find people who were out
there who were just trying to cause
trouble or going with the crowd but the
answer is the overwhelmingly peaceful
protests were there because of police
brutality you say that first not as an
aside or at the end completely
disastrous interview but two totally
level with you I don't know that it
matters
anybody who would be disgusted with this
interview is already not voting for
Donald Trump anybody who just watches
Fox News and gets in line and is
planning to vote for Trump is going to
vote for him anyway regardless of this
interview so we've got to hit that slice
who might change their minds and I don't
know that many of those folks are
actually going to see this interview
it's tragic it's sad because this is
really exposing the lack of critical
thinking and and sort of thoughtfulness
and introspection that Donald Trump
experiences a total lack of and it's you
know if you really sit down and listen
to each of his answers you understand
the guy understands nothing he just
knows nothing he doesn't even you know
he he's there for a particular reason
there's a reason that with what's going
on he's being interviewed by harris
faulkner and he still fails to keep it
together in the way that this type of
strategy would hope that he would be
able to do just absolutely insane we're
going to have more clips from this
interview on the david pakman show
Instagram which is at David Pakman show
on my Instagram David Pakman you can see
me at a socially distanced outdoor cafe
over the weekend an incredible moment
just I just sat down outside somewhere
and it felt like a huge thing that's on
my Instagram David Pakman we'll take a
quick break and be back after this
almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
and news voice is a one of a kind mobile
app that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's totally
free to use it's a great tool to have on
your phone news voice is not funded by
advertisers or corporate investors the
platform is supported by contributions
from users like you the news voice app
will have some really excellent new
features soon specifically for the 2020
election but they're wanting to expand
their team of independent journalists in
order to keep everything running they're
offering special rewards to anyone who
wants to give to their new Kickstarter
campaign which can be found at news
voice dot-com / kik giving a
contribution will come
with rewards like insider access to
group chats with news voice staff
members as well as access to a variety
of special features go see what news
voice is all about